the first woman to be confirmed by the
senate as deputy secretary of defense is
breaking barriers at the pentagon
in her first tv interview since starting
her new role kathleen hicks sat down
exclusively with senior investigative
correspondent
catherine herridge they discussed how
she's trying to bring about change at
the department of defense
if you look at these pictures on the
wall kathleen hicks who first walked
these hallways as a pentagon intern in
1993
knows how to navigate the building and
the bureaucracy
did you ever imagine you would be
sitting in the press briefing room as
the first woman to be the deputy
secretary
i would be lying if i said i expected to
be here and now that she's here
hicks said she will open doors a big
priority area for the president and the
secretary and i to make sure
you know women in uniform for instance
are well represented at the
senior most levels for those of us on
the civilian side to make sure that
women are represented throughout the
highest ranks of the civilian
both the career and the political
appointee course two days after the
inauguration
hicks's boss lloyd austin was sworn in
making him the first black defense
secretary in u.s history
what does this representation mean to
the force yeah well i think
representation absolutely matters it
demonstrates
uh both the breadth of capacity that the
united states has this incredible talent
pool that no
nation whether it's china or russia or
any other could match
when we bring our full talents to bear
is china outpacing the u.s
we are very challenged by china there
are certain areas where the chinese are
absolutely demonstrating a
high degree of proficiency and
investment no question in your mind that
china is the single greatest national
security threat to the us
over the long term absolutely
we've seen four years where the russians
have really
messed with our system so what's it
going to take to make the russian
president back off well certainly on the
cyber front we've seen very little price
paid by the
by the russians for continued election
meddling and cyber attacks against
um against the u.s government there must
be a price to be paid and that we should
anticipate the president will be coming
out with that in the next several weeks
in march hicks established the deputies
workforce council
to tackle issues ranging from diversity
and sexual assault
to extremism after the capital riots did
rooting out extremism
take on new urgency i think what the
january 6th
attack and insurrection attempt really
highlighted
is the degree to which we're seeing the
term extremism expand
and encompass a wider range of
approaches that really
challenge the u.s military to ensure
that its
force is living by the oath that we all
take to the constitution
at least 37 of those arrested are
current or former military members
in february secretary austin ordered a
force-wide review
to address extremism that 60-day review
continues through sunday so we're just
finishing up we're going to capture the
lessons learned after that
but i think what we're understanding
first is that uh
idea that if this is really about what
we commit to
within the those who take the oath of
office right so
the question is whether or not we're all
living up to those
ideals that we set for ourselves to be
focused and coherent
to be ready as a force and not to let
divisions among us
become sources of strain to our
readiness and what's the next step
next step is uh looking at our insider
threat program more systematically do we
have the right program in place
looking at data sharing across the
investigative services so for instance
with the fbi and others
we're going to look at our recruiting
processes what will the bind
administration do
to end sexual assault and sexual
harassment in the military
we've started a independent review
commission genuinely independent of the
department
comprised of experts in the field and
they're taking a hard look right now at
issues of
accountability at issues of prevention
the deputy's workforce council is an
ambitious
effort to address long-standing issues
and bring about
meaningful change how do you do that
without leaving the force feeling
beaten down change management is
incredibly difficult for exactly this
reason the first thing is to always
affirm
that we have an amazing workforce and
with all the challenges that we face
they are committed to making sure that
the that this u.s military
is the finest in the world these reviews
and the push for change
come as the department faces hard
choices on the budget where cuts are
possible
whether u.s troops should stay or leave
afghanistan by may 1st
on covet 19 hicks tells cbs news that
she expects the full force will have
access to the vaccine
by june or july tony this is good news
catherine herrich thank you very much
it's a wonderful interview
i know she's describing threats and
risks and challenges but but kathleen
the mistakes the way she was describing
it made me feel
more at ease actually i was going to say
she certainly seems ready for the job
nina shaw is a great lawyer in l.a who
says if you want to be a woman in power
then empower other women
she seems to embody that secretary hicks
you